dismembered limbs exploding eyeballs and
one very uncomfortable torture scene how
these movies manage to avoid an R rating
is anyone's Guess The Dark Knight is an
amazing film and widely considered to be
one of the best superhero movies of all
time Christopher Nolan's gritty
installment and the Batman franchise is
brilliantly done and the Joker was one
of Heath Ledger's best roles helping to
drive Batman to a darker more complex
understanding of himself and the nature
of Good and Evil
[Music]
it's a little surprising then that the
film didn't score in our rating The Dark
Knight doesn't shy away from violence
even if it isn't particularly bloody
case in point the infamous Pencil Trick
even Wally Fister the film
cinematographer is surprised I didn't
earn the Dark Knight in our rating he
told vulture it's kind of shocking that
the Dark Knight ended up being PG-13
somehow Nolan always has some magic with
the MPAA lo and behold he has a pencil
and I'm like you are not getting the
PG-13 with that there's no way this is
going in he's driving this pencil
through a guy's head and I was wrong so
how'd they managed to avoid they are
rating by using the Pencil Trick as a
joke according to Fister I thought if it
has the right amount of levity we'll
sell this and it won't come off as being
violent but it'll come off as being a
magic trick and it will come off as
being a punchline and it was
taken a 2008 action thriller starring
Liam Neeson was a box office star that
earned over 226 million dollars
worldwide launched countless internet
memes and firmly ingrained itself in
popular culture it might seem as though
the film will be prime R rated material
but it actually managed to pull in a
PG-13 rating taking could have easily
been rated R it has shocking violence
including an alarming torture scene that
had to be heavily edited for the PG-13
version wake up I need you to be focused
the extended hard occurred features even
more graphic violence in this scene
Nissan's Brian Mills stabs a man with
two metal nails so he can electrocute
him taken also deals with human
trafficking showing moments of hard drug
use and implied sexual assaults with
several female characters realistic and
extreme portrayals of violence are not
acceptable in the mpaapg 13 rating and
gushing blood is what usually pushes it
into our territory but even with all the
violence hand and combat scenes and
bullets flying everywhere taken managed
to pull off the more financially
lucrative PG-13 rating probably because
they kept most of the blood and gore to
a minimum
the found footage horror genre has
always been compelling who doesn't love
a freaky dash of realism in their scary
movie Cloverfield the first in a
multi-film franchise premiered in 2008
seemingly just another teen monster
movie with too many jumpers however
Cloverfield was a massive box office hit
bringing in over 172 million dollars
worldwide and landing on a few best
horror films of the decade list yet this
surprisingly frightening film features
more than a few scenes of shocking Gore
the gruesome nature of the movie
probably should have earned it a higher
rating one scene in particular stands
out as Lizzie coupland's Marlena begins
bleeding from the eyes and then quite
literally explodes the film's monster
which isn't shown to the audience until
almost halfway through is the size of a
city building meaning that his favorite
thing to do is eat people without any
concern for our delicate viewers
sensibilities the monster crunches away
through a few humans usually this much
Gore would be enough to put the brakes
on a PG-13 rating however producer JJ
Abrams somehow managed to keep the Team
friendly rating
live-action motion capture became
incredibly popular during the early
2000s but when a cinematic adaptation of
the ancient English poem Beowulf was
released in 2007 only three other films
had used the technology Beowulf starred
Angelina Jolie John Malkovich and
Anthony Hopkins or more accurately CG
versions of them even though the film
was entirely CGI it's incredibly
realistic for the most part so when
critics and viewers left the cinema they
left wondering was that Angelina Jolie
in the nude or just her character it's a
scene that Jolie later admitted made her
feel exposed despite its animated
classification in fact the actor told
reporters at the premiere that the
film's MPAA rating surprised her saying
it's remarkable it has the rating it has
it's quite an extraordinary film and
some of it shocked me Beowulf is
incredibly violent more so than his
original poem
Spears arms heads blood and dismembered
limbs rushed at the audience because it
was also shot in 3D the film was so
shocking to audiences that in the UK
where I was given a 12a rating the
British Board of film classification
received more complaints about Beowulf
than any other movie that year not only
does the film feature plenty of nudity
and the occasional incest joke but the
amount of blood that spurts out of
bodies along with various floating
organs is overwhelmingly gratuitous
animated or not going into a movie about
a giant tape on an island filled with
other giant monsters you have to expect
at least a little bit of monster Mayhem
2017's Kong Skull Island doesn't
disappoint when it comes to creature
Gore seeing a few soldiers get eaten and
thrown around or a lizard forcibly
losing its tongue shouldn't come as a
surprise what is surprising however is
just how graphic it all is when it
happens so much of the film is wonton
violence monster dismemberment and the
over-the-top display of blood arcing
Through the Jungle and while a giant
spider impaling a man isn't going to
keep audiences from the theater it
should maybe come with a harder rating
than PG-13 whoa whoa whoa no no no no
need for that come on now for director
Jordan vote Roberts however the violence
in the film makes sense he cited
Apocalypse Now as one of his main
influences while also packing Skull
Island for The Not So subtle references
to other Vietnam Classics regardless the
sight of a man's arm being ripped off
usually remains and rated our territory
maybe it's this borderline
cartoonishness that gives Kong Skull
Island a pass
might be surprised to see the
Blockbuster Bond film Casino Royale on
this list but there are more than a few
scenes at College PG-13 rating into
question in 2006 Casino Royale felt like
a groundbreaking new take on James Bond
it was grittier and more emotional with
the bond struggling with the violence
inherent in his role a self-awareness
not seen before in the usually Carefree
womanizer it was also a box office smash
earning over 605 million dollars
worldwide with the darker themes came
more graphic and explicit scenes of
violence but secretly in the film's
intense portrayal of torture towards the
end of the film bond is captured by Le
Chief and tortured in a particularly
memorable scene and while we won't get
into specifics in order to get its PG-13
rating bonds torture along with several
other fight scenes had to be cut down
but should you come across the extended
edition of the film be prepared for
Bond's house of pain to carry on for
longer achieve to make some unsavory
comments about bonds physique and a
little more blood and the fight scenes
much like bombs escape from the Sheep's
torture Casino Royale barely made it out
without an hour rating Sam raymi and
noted horror underwire Aficionado wrote
and directed the 2009 film Drag Me to
Hell this campy supernatural horror film
was mainly marketed as a team flag
filled with young actors like Alison
Lowman and Justin Long shock value
special effects and dark humor and for
the most part Drag Me to Hell delivers
on that score it also delivers on the
gore and many of the violent scenes in
the film are shockingly bloody the most
famous involves Mrs garnouche an old
woman hell-bent on Revenge after being
denied an extension on her mortgage loan
and Christine the young bank teller who
denied it when Mrs garnu shoves her arm
down Christine's throat literally
Christine manages to overpower her using
an anvil what happens next is equal
parts gross and comedic the Anvil
crushes Mrs garnisha's head causing her
eyes to explode and land in Christine's
Mouth More the mbaa allows for
depictions of Islands in PG-13 movies
the line is drawn are both realistic and
extreme or persistent since arms down
throws an exploding eyes aren't exactly
realistic depictions of violence it
makes sense that Drag Me to Hell was
able to drag itself out of the clutches
of an R rating that doesn't make this
scene or that several others depicting
animal sacrifice any easier to sit
through though no no of course not
foreign